Step four of the process guys is the big transition and again this is about my third or fourth
time explaining this.
There are miniature transitions in between each step and then this is the big transition.
This is the transition where we go from kind of pitching them and hooking them into, alright
let me grab your information and actually send you some leads, okay.
So what I like to do is after I explain the deal, which is I give you a couple leads,
we talk in a couple days, then I just transition really simple like okay cool what's the best
number and email to send the leads to, okay.
And they'll start giving it to me and they'll say oh well you know here's my email, okay
cool and then here's my phone number and this is then what we're gonna dive into.
Then what we're gonna do guys is we're gonna explain how these first couple jobs are going
to be handled.
They're going to be live transferred over.
So they just gave us the email, they just gave us the phone number and they go like
this.
Alright Jack so how this is gonna work, I need you to save and by the way guys, if this
is you that's gonna be transferring these first couple leads, which it probably will
be, tell them to save your number.
If you're gonna use a different number, tell them to save that number.
If you're gonna use a service, tell them to save that number.
If you're gonna use an in-house person, tell them to save that number.
Tell them the number that's gonna be calling them, but say something like this.
Alright Jack so how this is gonna work is these first couple.
I need you to save this phone number and save it all caps, name my company's evergreen,
put Nick, put answer, put money, put something because for these first couple what I'm gonna
do is I really don't want you having to spend a bunch of time doing this.
So I'm actually gonna call you with the customer on the phone and I'm gonna hand her directly
off to you and I'll make it easy, I'll just pretend that I work for you or whatever so
it doesn't seem like we have to explain a whole bunch of stuff.
But next time I call you and this phone is ringing, it is going to be me with the customer
on the phone and I'll just make a really smooth transition, introduce you guys, I'll step
out and you can schedule her for an estimate.
Sound good?
And by the way Mr. Business Owner, this isn't how we always do it, but just for these first
couple I don't want you having to chase leads around, call them, etc.
I wanna make this as easy on you as possible.
I want you to just get a taste of what this is like.
And that's how I explain it.
I don't ask, hey do you, like guys this is one of the mistakes I'm seeing people make
right now is they're saying, hey do you care if I live transfer?
We typically like to live transfer, are you good at that?
Do not ask questions, do not give them the option or they're just gonna confuse them.
Just say hey, here's how we roll baby.
First couple leads I'm gonna be calling you so save this number, tell them what to do.
Save this number, when I call and the next couple calls when I call you, I am going to
have a customer on the phone so do everything you can and look I understand you can't answer
all of them but do everything you can to answer because these are gonna be hot leads that
really, really want estimates, I'm not gonna waste your time.
Save my number, I'll call you with the customer on the phone, I'll act like I work for you,
we'll make this super simple.
Do not give them the option, that's it.
That's how you explain the live transfer process and the biggest mistakes I've seen is people
asking for permission, hey do you care if I live transfer these?
Nope, you tell them what you're gonna do.
People love being told what to do, I promise you, I know that sounds funny like I'm just
being hilarious, no, they like it.
They like when you sound professional, when you're bold, tell them what you're gonna do
and let them know, hey this isn't gonna be forever, I'm gonna do this for the first couple
so you can get a taste of what this is like after we put something together, if we end
up doing something, don't put too much pressure, after we end up doing something or if we end
up doing something, I'm just gonna send these directly to you or directly to someone that
scheduled your appointments but for these first, I just wanna hand them off live to
you so you can get a taste for it.
Guys, that's it, that is the transition process from who you are, we transition into what
you're doing, damn good reason, same thing, the deal which we just did in the last video
and now this is the actual transition step into getting the name, or sorry, getting the
phone number, getting the email, explaining the live transfer process and we're golden.